hello everyone I'm excited to let you  know that I will be in New York on on  May 5th for three big big events chess  works the first movie event the play -  live challenge and wholesome missing my  little sister's birthday the play log  challenge is where I'll be meeting and  playing winners from the app there's  still time to qualify so don't forget to  join on the play me page in the app the  play live challenge winners will also  join me at the other one event the chest  works in event with with first move  first move is a nonprofit organization  that I've worked with now for for a few  years that strive to bring chess - to  kids in schools all over the world I'm  looking forward to you joining me at  chess works and will continue announcing  winners and losers of the play -  challenge this year looking forward to  seeing you in New York this may